remercions
donc on a reçu dans la personne qui va
gagner
un hommage à la fois sobre et solennel à
l'image des funérailles qu'aimeraient
recevoir Benoît XVI son décès
consternent les fidèles ça fait beaucoup
de peine quoi
il a fait beaucoup pour le monde c'est
très difficile
alors donc un peu surpris Monseigneur
Lépine garde un souvenir limpide de ces
rencontres brèves mais attentionné avec
le pape qui l'a promu au titre
d'archevêque de Montréal
parce que toujours simple je pense que
son humilité était proverbiale donc
toujours simple toujours d'accueillant
et toujours bienveillant il a été une
source d'inspiration pour des millions
de personnes selon Justin Trudeau mes
pensées accompagnent les catholiques et
toutes les personnes en deuil le pape
Benoît XVI Joseph Ratzinger en 1927
grandi dans une famille pieuse
d'Allemagne ordonnée prêtre en 1951 il
gravit rapidement les échelons
ecclésiastiques Jean-Paul II en fera son
bras droit on nommant préfet de la
Congrégation de la doctrine de la foi
les problèmes de la moralité de l'homme
doivent être de nouveau pensée dans
l'identité des grandes données de la foi
quand on est de la tradition humaine
théologien aguerri il a soit sa vision
conservatrice de la société dans un
monde en plein changement
en 2005 Joseph Ratzinger et sacré pack
Benoît XVI un pontificat pour le moins
ou le marqué par les scandales de
pédocriminalité au sein du clergé ce
qu'on lui a toujours reproché encore
aujourd'hui pour
dire nous l'Église catholique on savait
on a préféré regarder
à Dieu de m'éclairer en 2013 sa
démission inattendue crée une onde de
choc je trouvais ça juste triste de
penser que comme pape il y avait il y
avait laissé tomber les gens qui sont
croyants je pense que ce que l'histoire
retiendra c'est le fait qu'il est
démissionné il n'était pas équipé cet
homme-là je pense pour faire face au
magouilles à la corruption et à cette
espèce de devoir incroyable qui était
son parti dans les dernières années
Benoît XV a passé ces dernières années
dans un monastère au Vatican dans
l'ombre de son successeur François 1er
ici Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal